this is a production of Cornell
University
one so today if any mentioned we're
going to talk a little bit about my work
on organic no-till soybean systems so I
don't have enough time to share all the
work that I've been involved in over the
last two years but I want to do at least
introduce you to some of the projects
that i have been working on a cornell
and really i've been involved in five
main projects that we can organize under
three main topics or themes so the first
one is winter cereal thermal models so
we're working with cereal rye barley and
triticale 12 cultivars across those
species so this work is in New York as
well as in Maryland where we're working
with Stephen Mirsky at the USDA so this
is really going to help us predict
phonology and a cover crop biomass speak
a little louder yes i can i will try to
thank you so we're also working on the
trade-offs looking at the trade-offs
between forage quality and yield for
winter cereals that are grown as Forge
double crops so double cropping systems
that dairy producers might be employing
on their farm and so this work is with
Korean Kettering's and a really big
group of extension educators and farmers
we have a lot of sites throughout New
York as well as Maryland so it's been a
lot of fun to work with such a big team
and then finally my last three projects
really fall under the umbrella of these
cover crop based organic rotational
no-till soybean systems and so that uses
a roller crimper which you can kind of
see this implement on the front of the
tractor here it's used to terminate the
cover crops so roll them down flat and
I'm going to talk about this at length
and so these projects range from system
economics all the way to focus more on
wheat ecology and so today I'm going to
talk about one of these projects where
we're looking at mixtures of barley and
cereal rye to enhance weed suppression
in these systems and these aren't just
you know disparate projects there is a
common thread here and that's that they
all involve winter cereals so either as
a cover crop for weed suppression or as
forage for dairy producers so other than
a really long name what is cover crop
based organic rotational no feel soybean
some of you might not be familiar with
this system this photograph is from the
Musgrave research far
roar in New York and so what I've
highlighted here this is how you would
typically prepare the soil so you have
your primary tillage your secondary
tillage and then you can come in and
plant for instance your soybean crop so
in contrast to that with these cover
crop based systems you need to start
with a cover crop in the fall so what
you're looking at here is cereal rye and
barley this would be planted in
mid-september and then when it reaches
an thesis so mid to early June so i
should say mid May early June they're
ready to be terminated with the roller
crimper and that's what it looks like
after that roller crimpers passed over
those cover crops forming a nice thick
cover crop mulch that provides your weed
suppression and then you can know till
plant through that cover crop mulch for
these notes Oh based systems so we've
established you have your tillage based
management and then your cover crop base
no-till and so why would farmers be
interested in this different type of
soybean production if you think back to
2013 we had really wet June and August
in the Northeast and if we look at a
photo from Aurora you can see a lot of
surface erosion washing out as soybeans
here in these tillage based systems and
then up lots Jason to it you can see
that the soybeans are growing up
undisturbed through this thick cover
crop mulch later on surface ceiling of
those clay soils you see standing water
and then again this cover crop based
system is just fine and so this is one
of the main reasons farmers are
interested in this system and that's
from a soul health perspective so in
addition to reducing erosion a lot of
researchers looked at increasing
biodiversity so both below ground and
above ground obviously associated with
reduced tillage or disturbance in these
rotational no-till systems we think of
system advantages it's really for
conventional and organic growers so for
a conventional grower that might be
struggling with herbicide resistant
weeds we can think of this as an
integrated weed management approach so
in a really simplified way you can think
of these cover crops is replacing your
synthetic or besides and for organic
growers that would be replacing your
cultivation
but of course these cover crops provide
many other benefits forgot to mention
here when you're comparing to tillage
base organic production we see boat of
thirty percent reduction in diesel fuel
and labor and what's interesting when
you talk to farmers or grower meetings
they're really drawn to this from a soil
health perspective we can talk about
energy savings but it's really about
reducing tillage in their crop rotation
and that's what's really driving them
towards adopting this type of management
system so this all sounds pretty good
you know is this the new perspective
farmers be sitting on their tractor you
got the roller crimper out front looking
at a field a winter cereals ready to
roll that down I mean we hope so that's
what we're working on we're working
right now on a farmer manual to help
address some of these issues that
farmers are coming up against so issues
related to weed suppression in
particular and one of the most common
questions that we get at grower meetings
is how does this fit into my rotation
farmers are typically planting if you
think of a corn soybean wheat rotation
soybean would be following corn grain
and so for this system to work they
would be establishing a winter cereal
like cereal rye after they've harvested
corn grain and that's going to be really
late in the fall and is not going to
provide enough biomass or uniform stand
for weed suppression so right off the
bat that's going to be a real trouble a
real problem for farmers if they're
stuck in this corn soybean wheat
rotation so from my perspective I'm
interested in kind of a food grain based
system it might have more small grains
so something like wheat would be a
really good crop to proceed this so we
it's going to be harvested in August and
it gives you lots of time to establish
something like cereal rye in early
September if you're working on a feed
grade based system a short season corn
silage would work and that's going to
push you may be into mid-september for
establishing that cover crop and what I
want to draw your attention to if you
look at these later planting dates so
these are six different cereal rice
seating dates these photographs were
taken on April first and if you notice
that these later planting dates along
the bottom you see a lot more soil
between those rows of
crops and where you see exposed soil
that's where wheat seeds are going to
germinate and that's a real problem
because in this system it's those early
emerging weeds that really dominate so
you've got wild buckwheat common ragweed
they're going to emerge before you
actually roll that cover crop in late
May so as you can see here that come up
in that stand in this case it's cereal
rye in the background here so if you
look at some of these data from
Pennsylvania you can see common ragweed
here in these violent plots emerge a lot
earlier than other common summer annual
weeds so that bulge in this plot here
indicates that the majority of that
species is emerging in this case an
early April in New York we would expect
this to be a few weeks later but that's
still going to be the majority of them
emerging before we roll down these cover
crops and so that's a real problem
because common ragweed emerges early and
it also can survive rolling and crimping
and this has really informed a lot of
our research this is not just a
phenomenon on the musgrave research farm
this is throughout the Northeast this
common ragweed just dominates in these
cover crop based no-till soybean systems
so in terms of previous research the
focus is really been on maximizing
cereal rye biomass so manipulating
seeding date and seeding rate and a
couple of factors like that emerging
from that as being this threshold of
eight thousand kilograms per hectare and
it's been suggested that if you can
achieve that you're going to get
consistent or adequate weed suppression
throughout the season but there's some
problems with that with this excessive
cover crop production and that's lodging
what you see here in really fertile
soils and it's also really difficult to
get good seat to soil contact it's
really hard to get good soybean seed
placement through a thick mulch so in
this photo here you can see that they've
added sandbags on top of these planter
units to try to get more down pressure
so you can actually penetrate that thick
cover crop mulch and get good seed to
soil contact and this is particularly
challenging if it's dry in the spring
and later on obviously if you don't get
that good soybean seed placement
germination is going to be poor and some
of these soybeans that do emerge you can
see our pretty chlorotic and you're
going to see a yield loss so for our
research and the way differs from
this previous research is that we're
moving away from focus on this maximum
biomass and instead we're focusing on
optimizing early-season shading for
optimal or for better weed suppression
and so to do that we're looking at
mixtures of barley and cereal rye so
cereal as tall and slender Barlow is
going to be shorter wider leaves and I'm
not suggesting that this is really a
true niche differentiation as you would
expect with the leguminous cereal but
these slight differences in phenology
stature and leaf architecture might be
enough to give us that edge provide
better early season shading so we've got
a couple objectives we're interested in
the impact of these cover crop mixtures
on weed suppression as well as
ultimately on soybean yield and then
we're looking at two main management
treatments so high residue cultivation
and then just standard no-till and again
we're looking at those in those effects
on weed suppression and soybean yield in
terms of experiment design we use the
split block design so replicated four
times over two years this was twenty
twelve to twenty fourteen at the
musgrave research farm we seeded our
cover crops in a replacement series so
you've got a barley monoculture a 50-50
mixture and then a cereal rye
monoculture and these were seated as i
mentioned mid-september at nineteen
centimeter row spacing I will note that
I have some photographs in here from
2013 but all the data I'm going to share
is just from 2014 I really just have
time to share a subset of all the
different treatments that were involved
in this experiment so we're just going
to simplify this in the interest of time
all right as I mentioned you've got your
to management treatments standard
no-till which is going to involve
rolling crimping that cover crop when
they're a ten thesis and then no-till
planting soybean on that same day and
that's it you don't have to do anything
else until you come in a harvest at
soybean in October with hybrid
cultivation on this about two to four
weeks after you've planted that soybean
you're going to have a single pass with
a high residue cultivator to control
some intero weeds and this is one of the
reasons why we use these wider soybean
spacing so 76 centimeter rows so it
facilitates the operation
this high residue cultivator and we did
include adjacent to those plots an
integral cultivated treatment and so
this will allows us to compare these
cover crop based management practices
through what would be kind of your
traditional tillage based soybean
management so to look at this roller
crimper a little more closely it
basically involves a cylinder with these
blunt metal blades welded in a chevron
pattern and it's going to bend or crimp
these plants at their base as opposed to
shearing or cutting them off as a mower
wood and this is an important
distinction because we want that cover
crop mulch to persist throughout the
season and when you mow these cover
crops down which has been looked at
another research it's of course going to
increase the surface area which is going
to speed up decomposition which is going
to result in poor weed suppression with
the hybrid view cultivator after those
cover crops being rolled this implement
has really wide sweeps on it that are
intended to slice through the soil just
below the soil surface it's going to
sever weed shoots from weed routes and
has really thin shanks with the
intention of limiting amount of residue
that's dragged all over the field so
this photo kind of shows that we had
some trouble actually I'm calibrating
this equipment we didn't get enough
cover crop biomass and you can see some
soil that's actually turned up between
the rows ideally you wouldn't see
anything you barely notice that this
piece of equipment has been run through
the field in terms of seeding rates we
based our replacement series on
Aroostook rye and then we adjusted for
differences in size and mass for the
barley seed which is why we refer to
this as density based seedings as
opposed to volume based seedings so the
slow density is equivalent to a one
bushel per acre and then this high
density is two bushels per acre you'll
notice the soybean this is a really high
seeding rate that's about 300,000 seeds
per acre which though double
conventional soybean seeding rates and
if you think about herbicide based
conventional soybean production these
are essentially weed free systems with
the exception of issues with herbicide
tolerant weeds so you're going to have
really high germination rates for the
soybean really good sealing survival
obviously very little
to no weed competition and so you can
use those lower soybean seeding rates
and still get maximum yield but for us
this is really part of our cultural weed
management so we use these high rates to
achieve canopy closure earlier in the
season which is going to provide greater
shading which is going to reduce the
fecundity of weeds so some of these
later emerging summer annuals so in
other words less see production from
some of those later species so this in
concert with that rolled mulch really
forms the basis of our weed suppression
and this boat is a little bit dark here
but what you're seeing is a shot from
underneath that soybean canopy here
that's completely closed you just see a
little bit of sunlight filtering through
and then you see that nice rolled cover
crop mulch there along the soil surface
in terms of sampling before those cover
crops were enrolled we measured cover
crop biomass and population
photosynthetically active radiation or
light transmittance through that cover
crop canopy and then after they were
rolled weed identification we looked at
weed biomass and then also soybean
density and yield we certainly measured
a lot of other things but again this is
just a subset of this experiment so this
is what we're going to focus on so if we
look at the interspecific cover crop
competition we've got cover crop biomass
on the y-axis and those replacement
series so that seeding ratio along the
x-axis and you've got your low density
and high density seeding rates and what
you'll notice here in the low density is
that I should first mention this depth
these dashed lines are your barley
monoculture and these dotted lines are
your cereal rye monoculture and then the
solid lines here are your 50-50 mixtures
and so what you're seeing here is what
we term over yielding at that low
density so in other words this is a
higher absolute yield in that 50-50
mixture of barley and cereal rye
compared to a cereal rye monoculture
orly the barley monoculture here and
with these studies typically that's what
you're looking for maybe if it's a
legume and it's a cereal you want /
yielding especially if these are being
grown for grain but for our purposes
we're really more interested in shading
so does this higher biomass here
actually translate into enhanced
and that's better weed control and I'll
also just no we actually didn't see that
in high density and there's a number of
different reasons here perhaps the CRI
has greater competitive ability
especially in what would be considered
more resource limited environment so
when we look at par transmittance so
that light that actually is making it
through that canopy we have the same
seating ratios along the bottom we
actually don't see enhanced shading in
that 50-50 mixture so instead you see
that part transmittance increases as the
proportion of cereal rye decreases so in
other words at that Syria where I
monoculture that's where you see the
least amount of light reaching the soil
surface and in that barley monoculture
that's where the greatest amount of
light is actually making it through and
when you look at weed biomass across
those seeing seeing ratios you see a
really similar trend as you might expect
of course if there's more light coming
through the canopy you're going to have
great greater weed germination higher
weed biomass and of course less weed
bomb ass when there's less light making
it through the canopy we saw this really
clearly in the field you have your
barley monoculture here and that is a
lot of common ragweed that's that's
emerged so we really did not have nearly
enough biomass production there or of
course shading to suppress those weeds
with the cereal rye monoculture we had
actually pretty good pretty adequate
weed suppression throughout most of our
treatments when we look at total weed
biomass you can see that common ragweed
comprised over eighty percent of that
biomass it was really dominant in this
system we had foxtail species so yellow
and giant foxtail made up about eight
percent and then a variety of other
weeds made up the remaining ten percent
for this experiment so if we're going to
then focus on common ragweed let's look
at those management treatments so we've
got common ragweed biomass here you've
got let's look at the difference of high
res ooh cultivation and standard no-till
and what we saw was about a twenty to
thirty percent reduction when you
integrate that high residue cultivation
and of course you can see by the error
bars this wasn't a significant reduction
but if you think of this
a farmer's perspective or a more applied
perspective reducing common ragweed bomb
ass by a few hundred kilograms it's
going to be really important for long
term weed seedbank management so there's
going to be a lot lower contribution of
weed seeds that are going to be a
problem later on in their rotation and
this photos from 2013 and I just wanted
to use this to illustrate how effective
that high residue cultivation can be so
these lighter rows here are soy beans
that are ready to be harvested and what
you'll notice in the standard note to
all this dark these dark patches here
all of that is common ragweed so when
you look at the hybrids of cultivation
you can see no common right weight at
all in between those rows so under
certain conditions this can be really
really effective act taking care of that
in tirol common ragweed alright and here
what we're really interested in is is
shading a really good predictor of
common ragweed biomass so you've got
common ragweed bottom s on the y-axis
again we have common or cover crop
biomass so combine both barley and
cereal rye biomass here and then part
transmittance on this right right side
chart and so really you can think of
this as a lot of the previous research
is focused on this relationship just
maximizing cover crop bomb a square as
we've shifted the focus over here to par
transmittance or shading and what we
found both in the low end high density
treatments as well as all the other
treatments I couldn't discuss was that
in fact shading was a much better
predictor of common ragweed so you can
see here we definitely had higher
r-squared values when we look at this
relationship and what's interesting to
note is as we saw with the low density
in that high here that over yielding and
that lower density treatment high
biomass production doesn't necessarily
result in greater shading so it
definitely suggests to us that we really
need to focus in on shading to really
tackle this issue of early emerging
weeds like common ragweed in terms of
soybean yield we actually saw no
differences between feeding ratio or
management treatments which was
surprising given the differences in
cover crop biomass as well as weed
biomass and on average we got about 40
bushels per acre which is actually the
lowest yields we
across all of our different treatments
and our on farm sites we typically get
45 to 50 bushels which is really
competitive with other organically
produced soybean so tillage based
systems when we compare this to the
intro cultivation we see about eighty
percent of that yield and so that's
definitely a substantial yield loss
there again this is a little bit related
to these were not very productive
treatments for us and of course you need
to factor in the fact that there's going
to be a thirty percent reduction in
diesel fuel on labor with this type of
management so in summary we found that
early season shooting definitely was an
important predictor we're coming driver
of common ragweed bomb ass but these
mixtures of barleans cereal rye might
not be the best way to actually achieve
that enhanced shading we're definitely
encouraged to continue pursuing this
because pre-empting that common ragweed
biomass is just so critical for
addressing these issues for farmers in
the Northeast we also found the irazoo
cultivation was really useful for
controlling that in tirol common ragweed
and you can think of it as a rescue
cultivation and for long term weed
seedbank management this might be a
really useful tool and then this is
actually different than what we'd
expected soybean yield was not higher
when you integrated that high residue
cultivation actually in some ways this
might be a desirable result for us
because what it suggests is if we focus
on cover crop management and so we can
really suppress those weeds with just
standard know till you're not going to
see a yield loss if you don't integrate
high residue cultivation and really for
farmers they're not that interested when
we've gone to grow armies and talked
about this in using high residue
cultivator because the whole purpose or
their whole interest in this is a
reduced tillage system so this idea of
higher education is is is not very
popular and we definitely see a high
potential profitability for this system
like I said if you get these competitive
yields in combination with this
reduction in energy use this is going to
translate into higher profits for
farmers and so with that I just like to
thank particular Chris pelzer Brian
Caldwell on the rest of our lab and all
the folks at the Musgrave research farm
I certainly kind of done this
research without everyone's assistance
and support so there's time I'd love to
take some questions thank you this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu